tf à 20h avec dominique baudis attentat
contre une synagogue à paris quatre
morts dix blessés
il a eu lieu en fin d'après midi rue
copernic dans le 16e arrondissement
deux suspects ont été interpellés la
guerre en irak notre envoyé spécial
robert bichard nous présente ce soir les
trois fronts ouverts en territoire
irakien
valéry giscard d'estaing au salon de
l'auto à acheter français le président
de la république a également précisé
il faut maintenir la limitation des
importations japonaises grève en pologne
succès complet le mot d'ordre de grève
d'une heure lancé par les syndicats
indépendants a été très largement suivi
oui ignoble attentat raciste a été
commis aujourd'hui en fin d'après-midi
la paris contre une synagogue de la rue
copernic dans le 16e arrondissement un
engin explosif de très grandes
puissances a tué quatre personnes
ces autres ont été grièvement blessés la
bombe a explosé au moment où plusieurs
centaines d'israélites étaient réunis à
l'intérieur de la synagogue pour prier
en cette veille de saba quelques minutes
plus tard deux suspects ont été arrêtés
par la police
et puis une demi heure environ après
l'attentât il a été revendiqué par un
coup de téléphone à l' agence
france-presse
revendiquée par un homme affirmant
parler au nom des faisceaux
nationalistes européens quelques minutes
également après cette épouvantable
attentats monsieur christian benêt le
ministre de l'intérieur s'est rendu sur
les lieux rue copernic où il a fait une
première déclaration fut rendu
immédiatement sur place
avec mon directeur de cabinet monsieur
vallini le prophète police monsieur
somveille et les plus hautes autorités
de la police parisienne
nous avons rencontré les représentants
de la communauté
nous partageons son indignation et je
supplie la communauté de considérer
qu'en l'occurrence le ministre de
l'intérieur réagit comme s'il était un
jeune israélites
mais je supplie ses jeunes israélite de
ne pas provoquer l'escaladé sous le choc
peu de réactions encore on sait
seulement que plusieurs groupes
sionistes appellent à une manifestation
de protestation demain à 20 heures place
de l'opéra et puis nous attendons un
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux qui se
trouve sur place des images de cette
explosion qui a littéralement dévasté la
rue copernic
on attend également d'autres réactions
peut-être une réaction du palais de
l'elysée avant la fin de ce journal
quoi qu'il en soit nous vous tiendrons
évidemment au courant de tous les
développements de cette affaire tragique
la journée qui s'achève a peut être été
marquée par un tournant dans le conflit
entre l'irak et l'iran durant la
première semaine de guerre les irakiens
avaient réussi à pénétrer assez
profondément chez leurs ennemis l'iran
henry poster principalement par des
raids de chasseurs bombardiers
mais au bout de quelques jours on a vu
les positions se stabilisent et
aujourd'hui
l'irak affirme que ses troupes vont se
retrancher pour tenir les positions
acquises et au même moment l'iran
annonce une contre offensive alors le
sort des armes va-t-il basculer les
commentateurs militaires estiment que
deux hypothèses sont ouvertes
ou bien on s'achemine vers une guerre de
position une guerre d'usure
une guerre de tranchées qui pourrait
durer longtemps ou bien on risque de
voir les deux pays s'engageaient dans
une escalade dont on ne sait pas
jusqu'où elle pourrait conduire en tout
cas ce soir nous vous présentons à la
fin de cette édition un document
exceptionnel rapportés par robert
buecher l'envoyé spécial de tf1
il a parcouru l'ensemble du front en se
rendant jusqu'au toute première ligne
avec ce reportage de robert du chat est
à l'arrêt de st vous verrez aussi la vie
à bagdad sous les bombardements
filmé pendant une alerte
le document à la fin de ce journal par
conséquent en france aujourd'hui c'est
dans une immense cohue que le salon de
l'auto était inaugurée à la porte de
versailles et à l'occasion de sa visite
le président de la république a souligné
la nécessité de défendre l'industrie
automobile française
la défendre notamment grâce à deux
moyens d'une part les consommateurs sont
invités à acheter des véhicules de
fabrication française et d'autre part la
redoutable concurrence japonaise sera
toujours plafonné à 3 % du marché
je
la france est le seul pays d'europe qui
dispose de deux grands groupes
automobiles qui sont l'un et l'autre de
taille à affronter la concurrence
internationale concurrence
internationale qui n'est plus seulement
européenne qui est vous le savez
mondiale alors pour que cette industrie
automobile française continue de
progresser il faut naturellement ce
qu'elle ait de bons produits aux
produits techniques que ces produits
soient compétitifs et en même temps que
la concurrence internationale soit juste
sur le premier point c'est à dire les
bons produits je prends qu'il ya à
nouveau un effort de renouvellement et
d'adaptation de de ses produits c'est à
dire des voitures automobiles nous avons
vu le perfectionnement des modèles qui
ont déjà réussi dont certains sont les
plus grandes séries d'ailleurs que
jamais produite à l'industrie automobile
française ait pu nous voyant apparaître
aussi de nouveaux produits en europe
d'ailleurs encore au cours des
prochaines années
je crois qu'on peut dire je le dis aux
français parce que les français ont le
choix quand il a fait leurs véhicules
automobiles
qu'ils peuvent prouver dans la
production nationale l'ensemble de ceux
qui répondent aux besoins des
consommateurs et le traitement qu'il
soit très attentif à cet aspect que la
production nationale c'est à dire
l'emploi des travailleurs français peut
leur fournir l'ensemble des produits
dont ils ont besoin à leur aide qui se
compare à tout ce qui se produit de
meilleur dans le monde
lorsque j'étais ministre de l'économie
et des finances
j'avais indiqué que la pénétration des
voitures automobiles en france ne
devrait pas dépasser un certain niveau
le niveau qui a été fixé a été fixé par
moi même
à l'époque il n'a jamais été dépassé de
pluie il ne sera pas dépassée car nous
n'admettrons pas qu'il soit dépassé
aussi longtemps que les conditions de
dax est réciproque des marchés ne seront
pas substantiellement transforme alors
il ya un autre problème qui est celui de
l'organisation de la compétition
mobile en europe et dans le monde nous
nous concertons avec nos partenaires
européens parce que nous acceptons un
petit show bien entendu mais nous
voulons qu'elles soient qu'elle
s'effectue sur des bases équitables
c'est à dire que les conditions d'accès
aux différents marchés soient
comparables
si elles ne sont pas comparables il n'ya
pas à ce moment-là d'égalité dans la
confiance
ils ont beau se faire très discret très
effacés on ne parle que d'eux on ne voit
que ici au salon de l'automobile c'est
miraculeux japonais qui ne connaissent
pas la crise oh certes ils ne tiennent
encore que 10% du marché européen
seulement connaît il faut savoir que
beaucoup de pays comme la france d'ores
et déjà s'oppose à la pénétration des
automobiles japonaises sur leur marché
il faut savoir aussi que pour une
centaine d'automobiles japonaises vendus
en europe
il doit y avoir une voiture européenne
rendue au japon
alors il y a toujours la tentation pour
l'europe de fermer définitivement ses
frontières aux automobiles japonais
seulement les japonais sont conscients
de ce risque et ils ont déjà une
politique pour y faire face vous savez
que dans de nombreux pays européens
il y à un constructeur national qui se
trouve en grande difficulté deux points
de vue la france avec renault est une
exception est bien dans tous les cas les
constructeurs japonais viennent proposé
de s'associer à ce constructeur national
en difficulté et regarder sur cette
carte
ce qui s'est passé au cours des derniers
mois les japonais se sont associés à
british leyland
en angleterre ils se sont associés alfa
romeo en italie ils se sont associés à
seat en espagne c'est à dire que dans
l'avenir
et bien si d'aventuré l'europe se fermer
aux importations japonaises
les japonais pourrait associer à des
constructeurs européens fait pénétrer
leur automobile en europe se dire une
fois de plus une barrière
protectionniste nous auraient jamais
qu'une ligne maginot destiné à tomber
tout plat comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure nous allons vous tenir
régulièrement informés dans le courant
de cette édition des conséquences de la
tragédie qui s'est déroulée cet après
midi devant la synagogue de la rue
copernic
patrice duhamel vous arrivez un instant
sur ce plateau avec une déclaration qui
vient d'être publié par le palais de
l'elysée une déclaration du président
réduit dont nous venons de prendre
connaissance il ya quelques secondes je
vous la l'immédiatement informé de
l'odieux attentat contre la synagogue de
la rue copernic le président de la
république après avoir exprimé sa très
profonde émotion et son indignation a
indiqué il ya donc quelques secondes a
indiqué au ministre de l'intérieur
l'importance essentielle qu'il attache à
l'action exemplaire de la police pour
retrouver les auteurs de ce crime qui
soulève termine le président de la
république qui soulève la réprobation de
tous les français c'est une déclaration
qui vient d'être rendu public
à l'instant par la présidence de la
république merci alors je vous le
rappelle à la fin de cette édition avant
la fin de cette édition nous recevrons
très probablement le reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux qui sont sur place qui
sont arrivés sur place quelques minutes
après l'explosion et qui vont nous faire
parvenir les images de cette tragédie à
l'étranger toujours journée critique
aujourd'hui en pologne avec un mot
d'ordre de grève lancé par les syndicats
indépendants une grève symbolique limité
dans le temps puisqu'il s'agissait d'une
heure d'arrêt de travail
le mot d'ordre a été suivi après le 100
% dans la région de gdansk est assez
largement dans la capitale les ouvriers
de nombreuses entreprises avaient hissé
le drapeau national rouge et blanc à la
porte de lusine comme le leur avait
demandé le leader syndicaliste l'acva
les a le conflit porte vous le savez sur
les modalités d'application des accords
de gdansk
les dirigeants syndicaux et les
dirigeants politiques s'accusent
mutuellement de ne pas respecter les
clauses de cet accord qui avait mis fin
au vaste mouvement de grève de l'été
dernier si l'on ajoute à cela que les
manoeuvres soviétique se poursuivre le
long de la frontière que la presse de
moscou se montre toujours très sévères
vis-à-vis des événements de pologne et
que monsieur cagna va se rendre
l'urss avant la fin du mois on est en
droit de penser que la crise polonaise
n'est pas terminée une correspondance
notre envoyé spécial jean nous dominions
nous avons réussi avec succès notre
examen nous avons montré que nous
savions comment lancer une grève et
comment l'arrêter ces déclarations sont
bien sûr de lech walesa après la grève
générale d'avertissement d'une heure
qu'a connue aujourd'hui la pologne
à l'initiative du syndicat solidarité
une grève que voyait d'un très mauvais
oeil le gouvernement polonais vous êtes
des irresponsables disait qu'il la grève
d'après les accords de même que ne
devait être qu'un ultime recours ou
sabotées par aux arrêts de travail
l'économie polonaise pourtant déjà bien
malade
mais la date d'aujourd'hui ne touchait
que quelques ateliers dans quelques
entreprises mais à travers tout le pays
ceux qui n'avaient pas été appelés à la
grève par le syndicat solidarité
continuer le travail mais en exhibant un
brassard bleu et rouge les couleurs de
la pologne et dix ans le cette grève a
été un succès complet au moins dans un
premier temps les raisons de cette grève
faire pression sur le gouvernement pour
que soit enfin satisfaire les
revendications des accords doute dance
la date limite d'application avait été
le 1er octobre les ouvriers en fixe une
nouvelle le 20 octobre
ce n'est qu'alors que l'on saura si une
nouvelle fois des ouvriers ont gagné en
pologne ce qui est sûr c'est que leur
action d'aujourd'hui la première du
genre dans un pays d'europe de l'est
leur a permis de montrer leur force dans
tout le pays sans pour autant laisser
voir leur faiblesse brett que demain va
te réunis en plénum du comité central du
parti ouvrier unifié polonais
la première fois depuis le remplacement
d'edward gierek et par le discours de
monsieur cagna on sera peut-être demain
jusqu'où en pologne il est permis
d'aller trop loin
charles de mieux qu est un parfait vie
retour en france 13 jours exactement
après les inondations catastrophiques en
haute-loire des inondations qui ont fait
je vous le rappelle plusieurs morts et
une quinzaine de blessés
on peut déjà dresser un bilan provisoire
des dégâts matériels 350 millions de
francs pour ce seul département de la
haute-loire et encore l'addition
pourrait s'alourdir tous les secteurs
sont touchés
l'industrie l'agriculture le commerce et
puis bien entendu les biens des
particuliers
le chef de l'état le conseil des
ministres ont donc annoncé qu'une aide
allait être apportée aux sinistrés les
pouvoirs publics vont accorder des
indemnisations et des prêts sans intérêt
les mesures qui permettront de
dédommager partiellement les victimes
elles aider les entreprises à faire face
en effet certaines entreprises ont été
sinistrées à 100% c'est le cas entre
autres d'une entreprise textile ou
jean-paul la rivière a réalisé une
enquête que nous vous proposons
maintenant brives charensac très jours
après la catastrophe les camions les
pelles mécaniques et les bulldozer
continue sans relâche déblayer les
milliers de tonnes de boues de pierres
et de débris de toutes sortes que les
pluies torrentielles d'abord les eaux
déchaînées de la loire ensuite ont
accumulé au fond de la vallée la loire a
été mesuré à 7 mètres 50 au dessus de
son niveau normal
provoquant des dégâts on n'a pas encore
fini d'évaluer tresse en famille une
centaine d'artisans autant d'entreprises
commerciales et industrielles ont été
sinistrées des degrés divers dont 20
presque totalement et 7 à 100% menaçant
400 personnes de chômage à saint vincent
en aval du puits l'usiné de textile de
michel mauriange qui emploie 35
personnes figurent parmi ces dernières
bilan des pertes au moins 5 millions de
francs je peux dire que l'usiné était
sinistrée à près de 100% étant donné que
tout le matériel de fabrication stanc
matières premières dans son discours
fabrication ont été détruits à 95% en
partie emportées par le flot de la loire
et l'art est retrouvé le lendemain dans
un 50 centimètres de boue et d'eau donc
quasiment inutilisable vous aviez
beaucoup de machines ici vient nous
avions des grosses machines qui sont
derrière moi qu'ils servaient à
fabriquer des sacs de couchage des
couettes des édredons est à l'heure
actuelle elle cei n'est pas il n'est pas
rationnel engine d'allemagne sont des
machines électroniques dire si on pourra
les remettre en état
je suis très sceptique donc il faudra
envisager le remplacement qui demandera
des semaines des mois
l'actuel je peux pas d argent c est ce
que vous avez reçu une haine à bayard
actuelle nous n'avons reçu absolument
aucune haine des pouvoirs publics
d'ailleurs j'espère et nous aurons cette
aide c'est là c'est la seule chose qui
nous permettrait de redémarrer
parce que tout le monde ici est disposé
à démarrer mais avec les moyens
financiers nécessaires une enfant tue
l'aide que le président de la république
annoncé hier à chamalières est une
promesse de survie elle permettra
d'abord de maintenir l'emploi et
d'assurer la paix des employés pour le
mois d'octobre
ceci face à la catastrophe ont fait
preuve d'une solidarité exemplaire
depuis l'inondation de leur usine noyé
sous plus de 2 mètres d'eau ils ont
travaillé sans relâche enlever la boue
récupérer ce qui pouvait être sauvé
démonter les machines pour essayer de
les sauver de la ruine d'autres
industriels épargnées par les
inondations
on prêtait matériels et personnels des
clients et les fournisseurs eux-mêmes ou
consenti à l'entreprise sinistrés des
facilités financières
ainsi s'est manifestée à l'occasion
d'une catastrophe de grande ampleur une
solidarité nationale qui a redonné aux
habitants de la vallée l'espoir de
pouvoir reprendre leur place dans le
concert économique national voilà comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure nous
sommes maintenant en liaison avec nos
envoyés spéciaux rue copernic là où une
bombe a explosé en fin d'après midi
devant la synagogue faisant quatre morts
et une quinzaine de blessés
alors tout d'abord éric gilbert est ce
que vous confirmez ce premier bilan
écoutez pour l'instant impossible de
confirmer un bilan en effet plus d'une
heure et demi après l'attentât
c'est toujours l'affolement dans ce
quartier proche de l'étoile la rue
copernic où s'est produite l'explosion
va de la place victor hugo à l'avenue
kléber elle est encore entièrement
bouclée je vous propose donc d'abord de
revoir ce premier témoignage visuel qui
témoigne de la violence de l'explosion
et aussi de la folie meurtrière de ceux
qui ont commis cet attentat
ces voitures que vous voyez en dommages
et ou même complètement détruites sont
en effet à près de 50 mètres de la porte
de la synagogue 1 6 magasins dévasté que
vous venez de voir ces voitures ont été
donc renversée soufflées par la
déflagration à 18h35 maintenant nous
entrons dans la synagogue dévastait il
était donc 18h35 il y avait plusieurs
centaines de personnes venues assister à
l'office de ce début de saba
parmi elles beaucoup d'enfants qui
étaient donc assis sur ces chaises ou
et maintenant les plafonds de la
synagogue en partie effondré le rabbin
qui étaient là sur la chaire va
maintenant nous raconter exactement ce
qui s'est passé ensuite
il y avait des enfants qui célébraient
leur majorité religieuse
il est en train de chanter vers la fan
le fils et d'un seul coup il ya une
déflagration énorme
les murs sont tombés les glaces et les
gens se sont affolés j'ai dû dire à tout
le monde de rester assis faut ne pas
qu'il y ait des blessés par dessus le
marché qu'on est resté là mais je ne
crois pas que la bombe a été déplacé
pour la synagogue c'était pour la
synagogue mais pour la sortie des
fidèles car il y avait ici 600 fidèles
donc c'était aux 200 tu es vraiment
c'était l'intention de tuer y avait
combien de personnes dans la synagogue
et elle combien d'enfants en particulier
ici à cet office ou en général ici en
cette fille ce soir il y avait 200 250
go combien d'enfants ont été blessées en
t on et les enfants n'ont pas été
touchés les parents se sont jetés sur
les enfants ils n'ont pas été touchés
est ce que vous aviez dit l'accusé
menaçait que des menaces par téléphone
par lettre mais
même chez moi je reçois des coups de
téléphone à 1h 2h 3h du matin kike les
ce soir votre réaction de juifs de sa
réaction d'homme mais je trouve ça beau
minable parce que nous sommes des
adultes nous pouvons nous défendre mais
quand il y a dans une maison de prière
où on réclame la paix pour tout le monde
pour tous les êtres cet abominable de
voir qu'il y ait des enfants qui sont
qui sont visés car ce sont les enfants
qui sont mus et y avait aucune mesure de
protection particulière dit houle et à
tous les officiers à des agents devant
le portail
mais il pourrait ne pouvait rien faire
puisque même les maisons en face ont
subi des dégâts
le toutes les vitres ont été soufflées
eu devant moi tout à l'heure en faire un
enfant a été vaincue grièvement blessé
par des éclats de verre est en train
aussi de fuite de gaz et vous voyez vous
voyez maintenant la méhari dans laquelle
peut-être labonté d'après ce qu'un
témoin nous a dit tout à l'âge allait à
la synagogue
j'ai la synagogue il était 6 heures 20
j'ai aperçu deux jeunes sur une moto
marron qui déposait un paquet et faisait
fin de rentrer au 29 pour livrer
j'ai pas pensé que c'était un explosif
j'ai été faire don aux prises samedi
soir est ce que j'ai vu où ils ont
déposé le paquet oui ils ont déposé un
premier temps le paquet sur le capot de
la sur la page de la méhari en un
premier temps le temps d'engendrer la
moto et puis ils sont rentrés dans le
rang
ils se sont dirigés vers le vin peuvent
de ce fait moi je suis rentré dans la
synagogue et après qui sont repartis
rapidement
je n'ai pas vu si son parti je n'ai pas
vu s'il était parti étaient deux jeunes
gens deux jeunes gens d'entre eux 23 et
25 ans
ce témoignage semble confirmer dans la
mesure où le savez la police
interrogerait actuellement deux suspects
mais on ne peut pas en dire plus vu la
pole man qui règne encore sur les lieux
de cet attentat éric gilbert rue
copernic
tf1 et gilbert je vous remercie marie
laure augry avec vous quelques nouvelles
brèves incendie particulièrement
impressionnant à la poudrerie de
bergerac 900 tonnes de nitrocellulose
ont été leur proie des flammes ce matin
flamme de plusieurs dizaines de mètres
provoquant de nombreuses explosions une
erreur de manipulation est à l'origine
de l'incendié
incendie qui heureusement n'a fait qu'un
blessé mais qui a provoqué vous vous en
doutez beaucoup d'émoi dans la
population
des rumeurs et un démenti à propos du
sauvetage de manufrance rumeurs selon
lesquelles la société nouvelle
manufrance construirait des logements
sur les cinq hectares du cours fauriel
le démenti c'est celui du maire de
saint-etienne il déclare à ce propos
toute responsabilité toute possibilité
d'opérations immobilières est
actuellement impossible à cause du
placement en zone industrielle de ce
cours fauriel
après 33 ans de travaux l'aménagement du
rhône entre lyon et la méditerranée se
termine le dernier ouvrage de barrage de
vos grilles au sud de vienne a été
inaugurée aujourd'hui en présence de
raymond barre désormais le rhône
bénéficient de 520 km de voies
navigables ininterrompue la liaison du
rhône et du rhin ambition majeure doit
nécessairement s'inscrire dans cette
perspective elle se réalisera
si elle constitue vraiment une grande
ambition collective
l'état ne pouvant porter à lui seul un
tel effort il doit s'accompagner d'une
participation de l'ensemble des
partenaires économiques et d'une façon
générale de tous ceux qui à l'intérieur
comme à l'extérieur de nos frontières
bénéficieront de cet investissement
le parti socialiste souhaite le
désarmement de l'océan indien se veut
est exprimé par françois mitterrand à
lille de leur réunion il se trouve
actuellement
ce désarmement doit être effectuée non
seulement par les riverains de l'océan
indien mais aussi par les grandes
puissances a précisé le premier
secrétaire du parti socialise deux
élections législatives dimanche en
europe au portugal et surtout en
allemagne fédérale la fin de la campagne
électorale en allemagne a été marqué
hier soir par un grand débat télévisé
débat qui a posé helmut schmidt et franz
josef strauss débat qui a été suivi par
84% des allemands et qui a été surtout
consacrée à la politique étrangère et au
terrorisme
des millions en argentine le successeur
du président videla pour mars 1980 vient
d'être désigné ce sera le général
roberto viola
l'ancien commandant en chef des armées
le pétrole était le thème central de la
conférence de presse de omar bongo
conférence de presse que le président
gabonais donné cet après midi au terme
de sa visite officielle en france omar
bongo a rejeté l'utilisation du pétrole
comme arme le risque serait alors
d'asphyxier les pays consommateurs at il
dit puis à propos du prix du pétrole il
a souligné que tant que le dollar sera
en baisse les pays producteurs seront
contraints d'augmenter leurs prix et
puis vous allez l'entendre il a évoqué
l'approvisionnement en pétrole de la
france approvisionnement qui pourrait
être menacée par l'actuel conflit iran
irlande-france effectivement est fait
uniquement de nous a demandé si on
pouvait augmenter et
la participation s'est pas la
participation j'ai le moins un peuple si
nous pouvons les revendre plus que nous
les vendons et bien nous sommes d'accord
je crois que nous allons leur vendre un
peu plus de pétrole que nous leur
faisons jusqu'à présent le directeur
simon balle et le directeur de la revue
afrique asie vient d'être expulsé de
france il a été interpellé en fin de
matinée par la police l'expulsion de
simon mallet a été évoqué cet après midi
à l'assemblée nationale le député
socialiste laurent fabius a protesté
vigoureusement contre cette procédure
d'expulsion et le ministre de
l'intérieur a justifié cette décision en
déclarant que simon mallet était accusé
d'avoir lancé des appels aux meurtres
dans sa revue football enfin c'était ce
matin à zurich le tirage au sort de la
coupe de l'uefa dans la coupe des
champions nantes rencontrera l'inter de
milan
difficile pour nantes un match aller à
nantes dans la couche de l'uefa sochaux
rencontrera le boavista porto
saint-etienne rencontrera sans miren un
club d'école les matches aller auront
lieu le 22 octobre les matches retour le
5 novembre
et puis dans tout cela un match vedette
dans cette troupe de l'uefa bayern de
munich ajax d'amsterdam
le temps demain après une matinée qui
sera fraîche et brumeuse le soleil
reviendra un peu partout avec des
températures agréables
toutefois en fin de journée à proximité
des côtes de la manche le ciel se
couvrira avec des risques d'averses
voici maintenant le document dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure c'est ce
reportage réalisé par robert bouchard
sur le front irakien et dans bagdad sous
les requêtes des chasseurs bombardiers
iranien des images tournées par à
l'arrêt de sa compagne de robert dantzer
de l'après midi la capitale irakienne
s'est installé dans la guerre et entre
deux bombardements
rien apparemment ne semble changer
pourtant chacun sait est pressant que la
journée ne se passera pas sans drame
cinq minutes plus tard tout est changé
le bruit des sirènes pennec la ville qui
s'affolent les milliers de gens foncent
dans tous les sens à la recherche d'un
abri
et puis c'est le grand silence bagdad
attend la ville retient son souffle
pas longtemps
le fantôme iraniens font sur la ville
passe entre deux antennes de télévision
épique sur la centrale thermique qui
fournit de l'électricité à la capitale
le raid a duré dix secondes
et voilà le résultat
il
par un matin
mapangou
alors
les hôpitaux déjà plaint des victimes
des raids précédents sont débordés
surtout des femmes des enfants parmi les
blessés et les morts parce que les
hommes eux étaient à leur travail
bilan de ce raid onze morts 90 blessés
finalement la dc a fini par toucher
l'avion
le pilote que vous voyez en ce moment a
actionné son siège éjectable est tombée
aux mains des soldats irakiens
il essaye de se justifier il explique
qu'il voulait seulement détruire la
centrale électrique et que ce n'est pas
sa faute s'il y avait des maisons autour
l'avion lui s'est écrasé dans un terrain
vague le fuselage s'est enfoncé dans la
terre et à brûler seuls restent visibles
la queue de l'appareil lui faisant route
vers l'iran sur le front nord est
tout le long de la route nous croisons
des colonnes de camions et blindés qui
emmène des renfort sur le front sud du
côté de 40 chars et d'abats dans partout
les installations pétrolières ont été
détruites
ici à cassel chelem nous sommes à 30 km
à l'intérieur du territoire iranien
sur ce front la victoire les irakiens
est indiscutable les troupes iraniennes
se sont peu battus et ont abandonné la
ville en laissant sur place munitions et
armement mais les iraniens sont en train
de se regrouper sur les pentes des
djebels qui barrent l'horizon
plus au sud c'est la route de meyrannes
une route elle aussi renvoyée par les
convois qui emmène des renforts vers le
sud
tout cela sans l'affolement normes et
des renforts mais on ne sait pas
exactement où les mettre et on voit des
kilomètres de désert transformé en
immense parking pour radar char canon et
camions militaires
et voici la petite ville de meyrannes
environ là aussi la victoire des
irakiens et complète mais elle s'est
faite sans combat lorsque les irakiens
sont entrés dans la ville
il ne restait plus qu'un habitant est
pas un seul soldat
plus au sud maintenant du côté de basra
dans la raffinerie brûle
nous sommes au bord du champ telara dans
la région qui résiste aux irakiens ici
ils n'ont pas pu traverser la rivière
les iraniens sont retranchés en face à
deux kilomètres devant à badens les
militaires irakiens disent qu'ils vont
tenter de franchir le pont cette nuit
alors nous restons avec eux mais à peine
ont-ils tenté d'avancer qu'un déluge de
bombes de mortier de balle de
mitrailleuse
les clauses et aux aurores les irakiens
constateront que le pont a été détruit
à badens à midi
raffineries brûle toujours ici
l'implacable soleil du golf n'est plus
qu'une pâle étoiles on se bat au canon
et au mortier de chaque côté du fleuve
et lorsque le vent du désert chasse la
fumée et que le soleil perce les coques
davadant croyait au but
alors il se met à chanter le comprenant
droit qui passe et oran successives à la
folie des hommes
ce journal est maintenant terminée mais
je vous rappelle la formation principale
le titre de ce journal un épouvantable
l'horrible attentat cet après midi à
paris rue copernic devant la synagogue
un attentat qui a fait quatre morts et
16 blessés
nous à les revoir quelques images de
cette rue copernic tournée après
l'explosion par nos envoyés spéciaux
depuis le début cette édition nous
recevons évidemment les déclarations en
provenance d'associations ou d'hommes
politiques appartenant à toutes les
confessions ou à tous les horizons
les mêmes mots se retrouve dans toutes
ses déclarations émotions indignation
vigilance face à ce crime fasciste et
raciste
sur place nous envoyés spéciaux viennent
d'enregistrer le témoignage du président
du renouveau juif m hm berne qui se
trouve je crois en direct rue copernic
monsieur li s'est passé ce soir quelque
chose de très grave
vous étiez vous là
l'attentât s'est produit on est arrivé
lorsque les blessés et évacués par la
police
il ya même deux morts c'est certain
maintenant une voiture piégée a explosé
devant la synagogue
vous savez que ce soir c'est shabbat
c'est à dire que c'est le soir où les
juifs se rassemblent à la synagogue pour
prier mais en plus et simrad thorax et
une fête juive importante
ça veut dire que c'est criminel savait
pertinemment que ray des centaines de
personnes à la synagogue ce soir et
qu'ils ont voulu commettre un attentat
qui atteindrait le maximum de personnes
ya des parler d'un enfant à l'intérieur
de la synagogue qui prit c'est une
synagogue libérale est donc
véritablement ce un acte odieux que tous
les français j'en suis certain
condamneront on ne peut pas penser un
seul instant qu'il ya un mouvement de
résurgence d'antisémitisme néonazisme en
france en fait ce sont des groupes
marginaux qui représente peut-être tout
au plus une cinquantaine de personnes
qui actuellement essaie de faire croire
qu'un mouvement néonazi en france nous
n'y croyons pas et nous invitons tous
les partis politiques tous les syndicats
tous les démocrates à montrer qu'ils
sont derrière la population juive qui
sont contre la montée du néonazisme et
nous appelons demain matin une
manifestation devant la synagogue
copernic
au début de l'office à 10h pour montrer
que nous n'avons pas peur nous n'avons
pas peur de ces attentats et nous serons
là pour prier à la synagogue et à 11
heures
nous irons par une longue marche au
ministère de l'intérieur place beauvau
pour réclamer des mesures de sécurité
que nous réclamons depuis des années
dans cette communauté juive parce que
c'est pas le premier attentat
nous réclamons des mesures de sécurité
que nous n'avons jamais obtenu même 50
moi je vous rappelle que pendant le
courant de cette édition nous avons reçu
une déclaration du palais de l'elysée le
président de république exprime son
émotion et demande une action exemplaire
de la police
d'autres informations sur ce drame dans
notre édition de fin de journée elle
sera présentée aux environs de 23 heures
25 par joseph poli